[Music]
surrounded by bailiffs and medics
sixteen-year-old rory hooper emerged to
gray skies above houston station
for his moment in the sun
[Applause]
we filmed the teenager as his three
weeks underground
came to an end he said he'd loved his
experience
but was leaving to conserve supplies for
the remaining protesters
enabling them to stay longer rory's
mother said she was very proud of her
son
but thought he was looking forward to
some home-cooked food
at 16 rory hooper is one of the youngest
activists
ever to have gone underground for his
cause if not the youngest so medics will
be keen
to get him checked out and see what kind
of impact
three weeks in a tunnel has had on him
rory went below ground with his father
daniel
a veteran environmentalist known as
swampy who first became famous for
digging tunnels to stop a road project
in the 90s
and now remains beneath the gardens in
front of houston station
with four others a chip off the old
block
rory said his actions might seem extreme
but he felt it was the only way to raise
the profile of the campaign
to stop the development of hs2 in an
ecological emergency
see around the world that young people
understand the implications
they understand that they're being
robbed of their future and they're
saying
enough is enough with four tunnelers now
gone
below ground the rest are still playing
cat and
mouse with bailiffs the down south
in a video message sent to sky news one
of the activists
said a tactic of separating the group is
now being used
within three different groups now across
these tunnels um
so effectively they split this longer
tunnel in in half
so i'm somewhat on my own dealing with
that but i'm okay
our spirits are still strong the houston
tunnelers say they'll keep going for as
long as they can
sixteen-year-old rory hooper says he's
been
on an amazing journey which has now
ended with his arrest
lisa holland sky news houston station